Пане п'ятий президент України, дякую, знайли час тут на Мюнхенській конференції з безпеки.
Ви бували тут багато разів. Яка Ваша думка про нинішній стан дискусії
про Україну? Що, власне, Ви про це думаєете?
Якщо брати загальностатистичні позиції, є речі,
які викликають запитання, наприклад,
в буклеті, який супроводжує
Мюнхенську конференцію,
згадка України була найменшою за останні 6 років.
Я думаю, що на жаль, це є символічним.
Це є зменшення того місця в порядку денному
світової європейської безпеки,
яку держави і лідери приділяють Україні.
Це є надзвичайно небезпечно для світової солідарності з Україною,
ерозія цієї солідарності, тобто реалізація тої мети, яку має Росія.
Друга позиція - вчорашня спроба Росії протягнути "12 кроків мирного плану",
які написано в Кремлі, які працюють проти України,
і починаючи від так званого пошуку ідентичності України,
яку ми маємо погоджувати з росіянами,
і друге - це є поступове зняття санкцій проти РФ,
яке має бути погоджене Мюнхенською конференцією.
Ми доклали великих зусиль,
мобілізували європейських й американських політиків,
і позиція була знята.
Щодо сьогоднішньої панелі й виступу президента,
Ви знаєте мої принципи: я на зовнішньому фронті ніколи не критикую Україну.
Я вважаю, що в Україні і влада, і опозиція має виступати єдиним фронтом
для забезпечення захисту національних інтересів.
Не почуєте Ви від мене критики  й зараз.
Але є речі, які треба було зробити, наприклад:
жодного разу не прозвучала в промові назва "російська агресія"
або визначення Росії як країни-агресора.
Якщо ми хочемо, щоб працювало міжнародне право, якщо ми хочемо
цементувати солідарність, треба називати речі своїми іменами,
не побоюючись роздратувати Путіна.
Мова йде про те, що Путін має прибратися з України, зупинити агресію.
Тобто Зеленському треба бути сміливішим?
Я впевнений, що Україні треба бути активнішою, принциповішою,
Україна не має нічого боятися.
Закон, правда, міжнародне право, Господь Бог - все сьогодні з нами.
І якщо ти відчуваєш за своєю спиною таку силу, іди вперед.
Якщо ти маєш слабкість або побоювання, не їзди сюди.
Зеленський сказав, що треба, можливо, створити новий майданчик
для обговорення теми анексії Криму,
зокрема, з допомогою США.
Чи можливо це, які перспективи цього проекту?
Ви не знайдете жодного виступу мого на Мюнхенській конференції,
де тема Криму не була підкреслена як важлива й актуальна.
Зі мною їздили лідери кримсько-татарського народу,
ми доводили й доносили принципові речі, емоційні,
що відбувається в Криму, що відбувається з політичними заручниками,
що відбувається з фактично можливістю постачання ядерної зброї і установки її в Криму,
як центр небезпеки, які породжує Крим.
Я на сьогоднішній день, безумовно, хотів би чути саме таку позицію.
Замість цього на Мюнхенській конференції окремі лідери
висловлюються про те, що варто починати стратегічний діалог з Росією,
що агресія проти України не має перешкоджати обміну думками,
поверненню бізнесу  as usual, можливості економічної співпраці,
ставлення знову під сумнів те, що працюють санкції.
Вибачте, будь ласка, але під час відставки
колишній прем'єр-міністр Росії Медведєв чітко наголосив:
"Для нас найстрашнішим випробуванням було застосування санкцій проти Росії".
Вони зняли в Росії відсотки ВВП,
вони зупинили розвиток наукоємних технологій, і так далі.
І безумовно, що це є яскравим і найкращим підтвердженням
ефективності санкційного механізму,
який передбачає мінський процес.
На сьогодні вчергове підтверджено, що альтернативи
мінським домовленостям,
які були підписані рівно 5 років тому,
просто не існує.
Будь-яка спроба переглянути мінські домовленості або відмовитися від них
означає дати можливість Росії  вийти з-під відповідальності,
зняти з Росії статус країни-агресора, а відповідно -
і відповідальність в міжнародних судах, в міжнародному форматі,
в Раді безпеки ООН, і так далі.
У західній пресі писали, що мер Києва Кличко
зберіг посаду завдяки допомозі Джуліані.
Вас часто викликають на допити.
Чи не обговорювали Ви цю ситуацію із західними лідерами?
Якщо Ви вважаєте, що можливість
політично мотивованих переслідувань
за підписання Мінських угод,
за відправку кораблів для захисту Керченської протоки,
за націоналізацію "Приватбанку",
за забезпечення захисту України під час російської агресії,
в тому числі, наказ про контр-наступ,
якщо Ви вважаєте, що тут потрібна якась західна координація....
Якщо дозволите, я Вам скажу, потребується,
то на мою думку, це ганьба для України.
І я не піднімаю це питання, піднімають це всі.
Вони не розуміють, що відбувається, вони вважають,
що це є порушенням верховенства права,
вони вважають, що це є політично мотивовані переслідування опозиції,
вони вважають, що це є ознакою повернення в часи Януковича.
То мені тут навіть не треба нічого додавати, бо це схоже на божевілля.
Це точно всі вважають ганьбою для України.